Do you have problems in your life that
you're not addressing that you could
solve and answer is yes,
and it's an easy thing to figure out.
You sit on your bed one morning and say,
okay,
there's some things that need to be done
that I don't want to do that I could do
that would make things better.
By the end of the day,
what are they?
Well,
your,
your conscience will deliver those
suckers no time flat now,
and then you might have to say,
okay,
well how do I entice myself into doing a
few of those and if you ask,
instead of trying to force yourself to
do it like you're a tyrant and a slave
at the same time,
you can usually negotiate with yourself
so that you'll start to sort those
things out,
sort them out,
put your house in order and then move
out.
Move on and out.
Yes,
that's a freudian slip by the way.
So it's important because the thing is
you have a practice domain,
right?
There are,
there are things that are within your
grasp that you could fix.
Fix them and you'll learn.
You'll learn because it's harder than it
looks.
Fix them and you'll learn how to fix
things and then something else will
beckon as another problem that you could
fix.
You know,
you all have your problems.
What does that mean?
Like there's an infinite number of
problems in the world.
Some of them happened to be yours.
Why is that?
I don't know exactly,
but you have your problems.
Great.
Solve them.
You know,
one of the things I learned as a
therapist,
every therapist has to learn this
because one of the things you wonder
when you're first starting to be a
clinician is how do you not take the
catastrophes of your client's home with
you?
And the answer to that is because it's
immoral to.
They're not your problems,
their,
their problems,
like their,
their,
their life.
You know,
your problems are your life.
You don't want to solve someone else's
problems for them because you take away
the deep meaning.
That's to be found in having them work
through the problems on their own and
then you steal the credit.
Well,
I can help you with that.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
maybe,
but I don't help you with the next
problem.
Then.
So in any case,
you sort sort out the problems that are
right in front of you and you will.
It will make you grow very,
very rapidly and then you'll be able to
sort out more complex problems without
making them worse.